[Música]
hola buenas tardes soy vanina gross y
seguro en silencio hasta caminar acá en
esta alfombra roja donde estoy parada en
su mente se dispararon millones de
asociaciones sin mi vestido estoy bien
planchado si el pelo está acomodado si
me tapa el micrófono y no voy a poder
hablar si el collar es de mi abuela es
inevitable las asociaciones es
inevitable no interpretar es inevitable
no criticar y es inevitable no juzgar me
así somos las personas inconscientemente
lo hacemos pero no es imposible no es
imposible
soy payasa de corazón alma y vida me
dedico a esto
él es un teatro de máscaras
ser payasa donde lo que se expresa es el
cuerpo la máscara es la nariz es la más
pequeña que hay la que menos se esconde
pero la que más revela
esta soy yo cuando era chiquita
les voy a hablar de los juegos
los juegos son exploratorios a la
linterna era de esta miren esto
qué peligro no
este auto sigue siendo mío
era de mi abuelo que hubiera pasado si
no nos hubieran dejado jugar libremente
si hoy yo no sería verdaderamente yo
misma frente a ustedes
los juegos son exploratorios podemos
acompañar la infancia pero son sus
elecciones están en la búsqueda
constante de lo que les pasa en el
interior y en el exterior solamente
tenemos que acompañarles y observar
obviamente que si hay algún disturbio
pedirles que respiren que se calmen y
que continúen
la búsqueda de lo que nos pasa es toda
la vida como así también la de buscar
nuestra propia identidad
cuando empecé clown hace 20 años no era
así tengo 38 pero hace 20 años me
dijeron si tú misma jugar
divertite y llevarlo a escena y me di
cuenta de dos cosas primero que jugaba
muy poco segundo que todo todo el tiempo
que no era verdaderamente yo misma nunca
que había creado máscaras sociales que
era yo frente a mi jefe que era yo
frente a mi vecino que era yo frente a
mi padre frente a mi madre frente a mi
hermano no era verdaderamente ni yo
misma frente a mi pareja un horror
eso no está viendo
la búsqueda de lo que nos pasa es toda
la vida
entonces les pregunto qué vamos a hacer
con esto
yo soy teatrera como les decía voy a
dejar esto acá
y estos botines son míos
como les decía para mí nunca fue difícil
tener si me callo es parte del clown
porque el fracaso es parte del cloud
también si te equivocas no importa te
dicen adelante mostrarlo y vos lo puedes
creerlo
qué pasa si ahora les dijera
tengo pene
qué pasaría a no estaba previsto esto
señor camarógrafo
esto no importa quedar atrás que pasa si
les digo tengo pene dejaría de ser mujer
levante la mano quien piensa que mis
genitales definen la identidad de mi
sexo
levante la mano quien dice un travesti
en lugar de decir una travesti
y sinceras ahí están mis papás y mi mamá
mi papá y mi mamá
ellos aprendieron a decir una travesti
porque mis amigas se sientan en la mesa
de mi casa y sería una falta de respeto
nombrarlas de otra manera estamos
hablando de identidad no les voy a
contar una anécdota mientras me acomodo
el botín que son penalti míos cuando
quieran jugamos
una vez dando teatro en tercer grado en
comedia dell'arte en una escuela muy
hermosa pido a los alumnos que traigan
un traje de payaso
no el traje clásico el estereotipo de el
sablón botones la paz la parte más
arriesgada de uno mismo aquellas cosas
que le divertiría salir a la calle pero
no se animasen a usar
entonces cada uno tenía que buscar sus
aspectos personales cada uno y también
estoy
incorporando el lenguaje inclusivo es
para que ustedes entre nosotros también
lo podamos hacer no porque es algo que
nos cuesta pero hay muchas personas
trans
voy a nombrar el nombre ficticio de la
persona
gazpacho trajo un hermoso traje de hada
cuando comenzó el bullying obvio él se
sintió mal
y al resto le dije en este momento
el pudo trabajar con su deseo y somos
libres cuando somos lo que queremos ser
deberían estar trabajando en sus
cuestiones personales en sus inquietudes
y sobre todo que no molesten
miren tengo
voy a poner ejemplos así para no poner
las fotos pero tengo 10 o 20 amigas
travestis algunas voy a nombrar porque
son parte de mi familia
marlene wáyar carla morales también
varones trans como emmanuel fernández
queridísimas personas no tengo tantas
como quisiera no tengo tantos como
quisiera por la violencia que existe el
índice promedio de muerte de una
travesti de 32 años por transfobia
32 años por transfobia no en la
transexualidad lo que conduce a una
persona a una consulta médica es la
relación con el conjunto de normas
sociales lo que dificultan la vida
cotidiana de una persona trans es ir a
la guardia de un hospital por
broncoespasmo y que te pregunten por qué
tenés genitales es ir al supermercado a
comprarle algo a tu hija y que te la
cajera te sugiere porque no le compras
otra cosa es ver a un niño llorar y
decirle no llores porque se suman y con
y entre la baja expectativa de vida que
se mueran a los 32 años entendemos que
es a causa del abandono de los estados
el abandono de la sociedad nosotros que
abandonamos y la expulsión de la propia
familia
ay qué despatologizar la transexualidad
no es un trastorno de identidad no hay
muchas personas que quieren ser así lo
podemos entender sí o no
hay niñas con pene y hay niñas con vulva
me voy a poner otra cosa porque acá las
charlas como que no son necesito yo
meterle teatro a la vida
espero que no se me engancho nada
ahora
qué vamos a hacer vamos a seguir con
esta humanidad o vamos a crear una
humanidad diferente vamos a hacer más
amable como decía mi compañero anterior
vamos a abrazarnos
podemos ver esa sonrisa quien besa
sonrisa distinguimos la niñez felices no
esta foto es en rusia en casa de niñez
con cuidados paliativos
esta charla es sobre juego de identidad
me parece importante saber lo que uno es
y con lo que uno juega y saber que si
uno juega de verdad es uno de verdad y
acompaña a una sociedad más amable
ahora
les voy a contar una historia feliz
porque si no nos vamos a quedar con esto
que decir hago bullying todo el tiempo
no acepto a las trabas que pasa con esto
pero hay muchas historias felices miren
esto
esa
es abrirla mansilla si miren este cartel
mi hija es trans y la quiero viva
infancias libres s escribió este libro
son en a su princesa les voy a leer un
pedacito página 28 espero que lo puedan
encontrar algunos que les necesiten el
estudio salió perfecto neurológicamente
estabas bien te derivó a un psicólogo
infantil tenía sólo un año y medio dijo
que tenía problemas de conducta el día
entero te la pasaba llorando y en la
noche despertaba a los gritos no tenías
paz me asusté mucho cuando vi que se te
caía el pelo obviamente te lleve al
dermatólogo me preguntó si había
fallecido algún familiar si nos habíamos
mudado si había pasado algo radical nada
de eso había pasado tu pelo se caía por
tu estado de ánimo
tenía mucha impotencia nada podía hacer
para mejorar tu vida tenía ya 20 meses
cuando me dijiste
suenen a mamá su princesa
y escuchen actos de valentía si los hay
en mayo del 2012 nace en argentina la
ley de identidad de género donde cada
persona puede tener su dni como quiera
ser y lohana con tan sólo 6 años obtuvo
su dni con un nombre que ella eligió
hermoso no
la lucha incansable de toda la familia
acompañando sus decisiones demuestran
que somos personas activas capaces de
decidir por nuestros cuerpos con
responsabilidad algo que antes habían
hecho solo los médicos como diría mi
amigo este libro lo deberían leer todos
ellos son mis abuelas
todos los deberían leer
como diría mi amigo patch adams ojo con
el negocio de la salud ojo con el
comercio de la salud amemos nuestros
cuerpos como una obra de arte
incentivamos a que las personas amen su
cuerpo como quieran ser ahora les
pregunto qué vamos a hacer
somos estados en blanco
somos esto
la nada misma desde la niñez tenemos la
oportunidad
de llenarla de colores y de pintarla con
libertad desde nuestros juegos que vamos
a hacer
podemos
a construirnos
podemos escribir libros podemos de
construirnos
porque también podemos saber que no
sabemos nada
y que podemos aprender nuevas cosas como
todos los que estamos acá haciendo una
cosmovisión diferente cuando una persona
tiene la oportunidad de pedir un deseo
por su mente pasan tantas cosas me voy a
hacer una varita mágica a ver si me sale
ahí va
es enrollando el papelitos y entonces
hay personas que piden
amor
hay otras personas que piden seguramente
salud
nos falta el que pide dinero o no me
pegaron las cintas acá
nos falta también el que pide
la felicidad eterna
son pocos los que piden ser
una más
como diría chaplin
cuando me ame de verdad
no debo tener miedo a cuestionarme
hasta los planetas chocan y del caos
miren
delicados
nacen las estrellas
queremos ser otra humanidad
queremos ser más amables empecemos por
nosotros mismos aceptando las
diferencias
amándonos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]